en este ejemplo queremos hacer la
conexión entre la notación de intervalos
y las desigualdades compuestas y la
pregunta es cuando escribimos paréntesis
menos 28 y corchete eso significa lo
mismo que si decimos que x es mayor a
menos 2 pero menor o igual a 8 bueno a
mí me gusta empezar dibujando una recta
numérica entonces miren aquí tenemos
menos 2 y como primero tenemos un
paréntesis eso significa que no lo
incluimos entonces aquí podemos poner un
paréntesis o también lo que hacen otras
personas es poner un círculo abierto y
después nos dice que tenemos cualquier
número mayor a esto hasta incluyendo 8
eso es lo que significa el corchete que
este número también está incluido yo me
imagino que los corchetes son como
pequeños ganchos y que agarran al número
para que sea parte de ese rango mientras
que los paréntesis como son redondos
no lo agarran por lo tanto si para mí
esta anotación del intervalo que va de
menos dos con paréntesis a ocho con
porsche te significa que tenemos
cualquier valor de x que sea
estrictamente mayor a 2 x debe ser mayor
a 2 y también debe ser menor o igual a 8
así que sin duda esto es verdadero